makes me stand properly and it makes me
kind of want to do this too butts are a
big deal in hollywood whether that's
showing it off or not showing it at all
everybody's got a preference so we're
looking at all the times actors were
forced to pad their butt for a roll
and we promise we'll do our absolute
best to make as many booty puns as we
can
number one look out here comes the
spider butt we don't care about the
identity of spider-man we just gotta
know which one had the fake booty but
one of us has a fake ass in their suit
see tom holland says one of us as if
there's a chance it could maybe be him
but then very quickly reveals that it
isn't i remember being on set being like
wow
oh hang on a minute unless he didn't
notice there was padding in the suit but
we find that highly unlikely was it
andrew or toby we need to know you can
figure out that for yourselves cheeky
tom
listen we're not the kind of people who
pay to stare at booties please just tell
us he's just stirring the pot old tom he
can't help himself with great power
comes great responsibility you saw that
pun coming from a mile away didn't you
number two why wasn't tom cruise afraid
of the dark because of his full moon tom
cruise was more than content to let the
world know he did all of his own mooning
in america made so why would he need a
fake booty for valkyrie he shut down the
rumors when he was made aware of the
circulating memes saying i have no idea
there was no prosthetic in valkyrie no
it must be a strange moment for an actor
to find out the world is trying to
decipher if their butt is real or not
number three this one took us by
surprise mr rogers i almost forgot that
suit did nothing for your ass the
internet that we can always rely on to
tell us the truth about everything had
people speculating if that was actually
chris evans booty and end game or if it
was a prosthetic or even his double as
far as i'm concerned that's america's
ass it's a very reasonable question
given captain america was fighting
himself but nope we're here to reassure
you that's all him through the magic of
green screens and evan stunt double
confirmed it that is america's ass
number four sorry not sorry unlike
captain america my my asses is a fake
ass paul bettany had himself a fake
booty for the 1950s episode of wanda
vision and he is unabashedly unashamed
and we love it it's actually been molded
to be a perfect ass elizabeth olsen said
her dresses made her stand more proper
and paul jumped on that comment that his
fake booty does the exact same thing for
him
our only critique of this next scene was
that they didn't have paul dano pulling
radcliffe's finger to operate him daniel
radcliffe didn't need to wear his
prosthetic posterior for longer than it
took to make for swiss army man and that
iconic scene where paul dano rode
radcliffe like a jet ski across the
water powered by farts they first had a
mold of radcliffe's butt made and then
put a pipe in so they could blow air
into a prosthetic butt that farted
number six the devil wears prosthetics
anne hathaway loved her butt pad that
she wore for the devil wears prada i
took it um at the end of the film the
best part it hangs in my office she had
to lose a bit of weight for the film but
to get that necessary size 6 booty she
needed the extra squishy bits brought
back in wait no the real best part was
she had it framed with a little plaque
underneath that says andy's ass
number seven in a whole other scenario
than daniel radcliffe penelope cruz was
also expected to move with her butt
crews loved her fake butt that she wore
for the spanish comedy drama volver she
begged the producers to keep it once
filming was over what we can't help but
wonder is why did she need to beg to
save her butt the fake booty was
important to filming as they were aiming
for a certain aesthetic the director
wanted her to wear the prosthetic butt
so she would resemble a film heroine
from 1950s italian cinema the director
wanted her to be sexy but more maternal
with hips and a lower register of speech
not from the shoulders but from her
backside and so they created and applied
a fake butt number eight maybe try out
chemicals on less sensitive parts of
your body before putting them on your
booty adam negantis was feeling
incredibly uncomfortable wearing his
prosthetic butt while filming the terror
due to some incredibly adhesive glue and
this thing that this stuff doesn't come
up no
and it's everywhere the poor guy was
just happy he was done filming because
he was exhausted but the booty put up a
fight and so adam sat in the bath hoping
that would help
nope so the prosthetics guy gave him
some sort of adhesive alcohol to help
him out but it didn't help in the
slightest and i'm rubbing it on myself
and just burning and that was the worst
day of his life it's too bad he didn't
have baby powder around that would have
done the trick number nine fake it till
you make it after julianne moore's
double dropped out of the big lebowski
pretty last minute she agreed to do a
scene where her booty would be seen only
they were not allowed to film her booty
it had to be fake does the female 4 make
you uncomfortable mr lebowski but it
sure made more a little uncomfortable
good for her for sticking to her
boundaries though it can be so easy in
moments like this to just cave under the
pressure of time constraints
number 10 who would have thought the
shakespeare adaptation would be the
weirdest on this list yes weirder than
the harry potter star being ridden like
a jet ski because frank crans wore his
butt mold on his
face a movie adaptation of shakespeare's
a midsummer night's dream took the
character of bottom a man who's been
turned into a donkey and did it with a
twist instead kranz's cheeks were
replaced with butt cheeks this is
highbrow comedy they wish to make an ass
with me number 11. dustin walked a mile
in women's shoes and it quite literally
changed him dustin hoffman were a fake
bottom in tootsie when he dressed
himself up as dorothy of course that's
not what's interesting about this story
though what is quite incredible about
the story is he asked colombia if they
would spend the money to do makeup tests
if they couldn't make him look
believably like a woman he didn't want
to make the movie he didn't want the
audience to have to suspend their
disbelief he saw the screen tests and he
thought it was believable but he said
now make me beautiful and they said to
me that's as
good as it gets he told his wife he
needed to take the role he said there
are too many interesting women he has
not had the experience to know because i
have
been brainwashed well that got
surprisingly deep number 12
this next one sure sounds like a pain in
the butt creature actor doug jones
played the little mermaid in the shape
of water he likes to find the heart and
soul of his characters before finding
their elbows and hands when it came to
the suit he was fortunate enough to be
able to go number one but that
prosthetic booty got in the way of other
business and when it takes three hours
to get into the suit and 40 minutes to
get out of it he had to think ahead as
jones put it but that behind of mine
that backside of the fishman which was
very sexy that sexy backside came at a
cost oh hollywood beauty standards
always come at a cost sometimes it's
worth it we're undecided on whether a
fish butt is though who would have
thought there were so many silly stories
about butts four-year-olds most
definitely well thanks for embracing the
silliness with us and here's hoping you
cracked up at least once did we miss out
on a perfect opportunity for a butt pun
let us know in the comments and thanks
for hanging out with us here at the
things